now a truly inspirational story about um
somebody who broke their neck and spine
and former rugby player ed jackson is
uh a first quadriplegic to reach a
summit of 7 000 feet along with three
others ed climbed to the summit of mount
himlang himmel
i hope i've pronounced that right in
nepal let's find out he's with us now hi
ed
are you well
i am very well is that how you pronounce
the mountain
seven thousand meters uh not feet which
is about twenty two thousand feet
um so
it's like a slight difference but um
especially when you were in the last
7000 feet of it um tell me how it went
um
it was an unbelievable trip i mean we
were out there for nearly a month um
completely off-grid for two weeks so
it's one of the most remote mountains in
the himalayas so there's no signal wi-fi
as you can imagine which was a pretty
special process in itself just us and
the porters and sherpas the nepali team
in tents for two weeks
on the actual mountain
the climbing period um
was difficult to say the least because
no one's been on that mountain for over
two years um it's a pretty
full-on seventh thousand meter mountain
and and it goes over a lot of glaciers
so um the crevasse fields have moved
quite a lot in those two years so a lot
of the time we were having to feel our
way
through it um we ended up with a 1200
meter summit day vertical meter summit
day which um which is a lot because camp
3 wasn't able to be set up and we
actually ended up getting to about 6 800
meters
which is a new world record for for
someone with a
spinal cord injury but it was um it was
very treacherous coming back down and
actually by the time we got back to the
crevasse field at about 6 000 meters
the snow had softened up um and people
were just falling through crevasses in
our team we lost our lead guide to uh
through a crevasse that was about two
stories deep we managed to rescue him
but then we had to take the decision to
call a helicopter rescue because we
couldn't move anywhere without falling
through a crevasse um
and at that point at six pm we were
about sort of 18 19 hours in uh the
helicopter said sorry we can't come and
fly at night so you're gonna have to
survive the night on the mountain so we
spent
a night at 6 000 meters with no tent no
food no water um just trying to survive
in minus 20 degrees
uh
so we're very lucky to be honest to to
have made it through um
an unbelievable achievement i'm very
proud of for the whole team to the
height we got to but a bit of bit an uh
rather more exciting end than we
anticipated
now you you spinal injury was uh after
you dived into a shallow pool i believe
and you damaged your your neck and your
spine but you know we've seen what
you've done as a result how can people
um support the sort of work that you do
and get involved
yeah um it's a good question so i i when
i had my spinal cord injury obviously i
was professional player before it was
very difficult for me
losing the ability to move and um i was
a physical person and my identity was
wrapped up in that and you know my
spinal cord injury still affects me
greatly all the weakness through my left
side i have underlying
um conditions sort of bladder bowel
temperature regulation spasms all of
these things that aren't very conducive
to climbing mountains but i got to the
point where
i was just constantly being told what i
couldn't do anymore
and i kind of got i had enough of that
and i just started to explore what i
could do and it started off by hobbling
up small hills and it's transpired into
climbing bigger mountains but
hopefully we can represent i want to
represent the the entire spinal cord
injury community but not just them
anyone with physical limitations to the
outdoors because i realize how lucky i
am to even be in that position to to
take on a mountain like that so many
people aren't every injury is different
um but hopefully by doing what we're
doing we can encourage more people to
maybe break out of the narrative that
they're being given being told they
can't do things and go and find out for
themselves so i set up a charity to do
exactly that to help other people who
are going through trauma use the
mountains use the outdoors to encourage
them to do that call millimeters to
mountains so people can follow that on
social media or my account at jackson 8
for more information um
but also i've been working with
burkhouse around adapting kit to make
the outdoor more accessible for people
with physical limitations because i
massively believe in the healing power
of nature a bit ironic considering i'm
sat here with like cold burned on my lip
and having spent a night night on the
mountain but to be honest um i don't
regret anything that happened over there
it was an incredible experience and
one i probably would never have
been through if it wasn't for that
supposedly terrible day when i had my
accident and my life changed forever and
i just hope that other people who go
through trauma and life-changing
accidents or incidents can start to see
the brightness on the other side and
stop looking at things they can't do and
start dreaming about the things they can
and take that first step towards um
towards a new life really
okay ed amazing story and well done you
i'm glad you all got back safely thank
you very much indeed thanks a lot thanks